I resist the notion that somehow China
is special or different from every other
country,
except in the obvious sense that every
country has some unique characteristics
in terms of Chinese history.
I know,
I think perhaps a lot of people in the
West don't realize that you only have to
go back to about 1800 to find that China
was the largest economy in the world and
its per capita income was not
significantly different from western
Europe.
You know,
so China was a major economic power.
China was a developed country.
If you go back further to about 1400,
you know,
China had a major navy.
It was exploring as far as Africa.
Uh,
so you know,
China was a global power throughout much
of history.
And then starting sometime around 1800,
we can argue about the exact date.
You know,
China went into a period of decline
largely I think because it cut itself
off from the rest of the world.
So it stopped having those benefits of
exchange with other countries,
which are,
which are important for,
for technological,
advanced and prosperity.
So I think Chinese people have a lot of
in a pride,
you know,
about their past and they're in some
sense embarrassed at the country,
you know,
really declined and became extremely
poor in the 20th century.
You know,
you had the Japanese invasion,
you had different European powers taking
little pieces of China's.
So I think,
uh,
you know,
I think the Chinese people have a very
strong drive to return to what they see
is their rightful place in the world,
which is a,
a major economic and cultural political
center.
You know,
I think Mao was fairly effective
political leader during a period where
China was trying to unify the country,
uh,
you know,
fight the Japanese and expelled them,
expelled the European colonial powers.
There's a lot of controversy about,
you know,
who played what role exactly.
And I'm not the best expert to,
to,
uh,
to be interviewed on the details of the
history of the 1920s in 1930s.
I think the important point is most
people in mainland China think that Mao
played a very important role in
reunifying the country and putting
China.
That kind of first step in bringing
China back as a world power.
On the other hand,
I think most people in mainland China,
uh,
think that he was a very poor day to day
manager and after the country was
unified in 1949,
there was a series of quite disastrous
decisions,
mostly on the economic front.
You know,
the great leap forward generated a huge
famine in which tends of millions of
people died.
A cultural revolution was a disaster for
most Chinese people.
So I think,
uh,
you know,
I think it's fair to say that by the
early 1970s there was,
China certainly was extremely,
we know it was poor than Subsaharan
Africa and I think there was a lot of
resentment on the part of ordinary
people about the condition and to which
the country had fallen.
So there was a lot of popular support
for some kind of change of direction and
Dung Sao paying I think was very
effective in channeling that,
that energy,
you know,
and quite quickly bringing about almost
180 degree change in economic policy.
So,
you know,
China's really interesting laboratory in
a sense that,
you know,
the same people in the same culture,
uh,
went down a disastrous road in the
sixties and seventies,
and just got poorer and poorer and
people starve to death.
And then with a few key changes in
economic policy,
the same people,
same geography,
all of a sudden they start growing at
close to 10% per year.
So it's a very powerful example of what
you can do with economic policy.
Uh,
but again,
remembering that the underlying
institutions are quite important.
And I think China had a long history of
effective government.
It had pretty substantial history of
private property rights.
If you go back far enough,
it had a long history as a trading
power.
So I think those things reside in
people's memories.
And once in a country like China,
once you shift policy,
uh,
toward strengthening property rights and
opening up the economy,
you get really impressive results very
quickly.